okay so so i'll be talking about nearest
neighbor which is one of the oldest and
most well weathered and most widely used
forms of information retrieval and
classification and you know just to give
you a quick example you know you take a
you know you take a photograph of a bird
you've never seen before you give it to
your computer and you ask the computer
you know what is this thing and the
computer has got some vast database of
images all of which have got some
annotations associated with them and it
just finds the closest thing and said oh
you know it looks like this which is a
Warbler or something like that so in
order for this to work well what really
matters is having a very good
representation and this is something
that provision community for example has
been you know improving by leaps and
bounds you know over the last two
decades so representation is key but
i'll be talking about 22 other aspects
of the problem which is a statistical
analysis what is the error rate of a
nearest neighbor classifier and the
algorithmic side which is you know how
do you find the nearest neighbor quickly
okay so so in terms at the rate of
convergence of nearest neighbor so let's
just say we have points from some
distribution in P dimensional Euclidean
space and each point has a label that's
possibly stochastic ok so the labels are
buying weed at 0 or 1 and at point x the
probability of getting a label one is
some ADA of X ok so very often a lot of
the labels are deterministic you know
the parts of the space where it's
definitely a Wan definitely a zero you
know ok so this this person definitely
has cancer this person definitely does
not and on this person you know 5050 ok
so in terms of the classical theory for
for the classical statistical theory for
nearest neighbor the first question is
can we give an error bound on nearest
neighbor but what is the error of the
no stable classify the defense only on
pnn like and we say oh the error of
nearest neighbor is like p over n or
something like that and the answer to
that is no and the reason for that is
that this ADA function this conditional
probability distribution could be like
this could be you know like really spiky
and so and so the smoothness of this
conditional probability function is
really key okay so so then the next step
is okay let's make a smoothness
assumption and the standard sort of
smoothness assumption in this in
Sullivan in this sort of nonparametric
statistics is that some sort of holder
continuity so for example with alpha
equals 1 then this would be a Lipschitz
assumption and later I'll explain why
this is really a very bad assumption for
nearest neighbor it doesn't fit the
problem at all okay but under this then
you get this error bound okay you said
okay well if you're the endpoints this
is the error rate of nearest neighbor
classification and at that point you
know it's just you're like Gulf you know
it's like because this means that it's
exponential in the dimension okay so if
you want any sort of decent error rate
it looks like you need exponentially
many points and so if the dimension is
50 or more that would be or actually
even a little bit less that would be
absolutely no reason to use nearest
neighbor right so this is if you do
k-nearest neighbor for appropriate k and
so we will spell that out a little bit
yeah and so so you might hope that this
bound is loose but then when they tell
you know this is actually an optimal
ground and why because there exists a
distribution for which the bound is
actually died okay and it's at this
point that you know the theory really
gets into the realm of complete
absurdity okay so of all the countless
possible distributions right there is
one for which this bomb destroyed and
therefore its optimal okay so so you
know if this were really a picture of
reality then we wouldn't want to use
this method but but you know fortunately
it isn't and so so what we'd like is
what we'd like for something and
something that's achievable for
nonparametric
estimators like nearest neighbor is
first of all bounds that hold without
assumptions and and these are useful
because then once you have the bound it
might not be pretty but it really helps
bring out what are the real parameters
that govern the difficulty of the
problem okay so once you have a bound of
that form and then how do you know the
bounds are tied when the upper and lower
bounds match on every instance okay so
we are interested in things that are
really right for the instance and not
okay so then let's talk a little bit
about nearest neighbor sir then this
problem you have them okay so now you
have some vast collection of points and
you want to find the nearest neighbor
and brute force is is linear in n and
you know which is really not appealing
if you have a very large collection and
so since at least the early 70s people
have been coming up with clever data
structures to answer these queries
quickly and so ideally what we'd like is
a data structure whose space
requirements just linear and whose query
time is little event that's all and you
know so for example if it was just if
the points we just on the line this
would be easy you just sort the points
and then when you get a query you do
binary search and so you would just get
linear and you get log in and then you
hope that ok so once we go into higher
dimension maybe we can do some sort of
generalization of this like one beam by
wizard and some of the data structures
have that flavor but unfortunately these
generalizations tend to be exponential
in the dimension this generalization
would it work out to be exponential and
and so here's just a sort of a troubling
example you know if you're in P
dimensional space then you can find two
to the people instead of roughly the
same distance from each other almost
exactly the same distance and so if your
endpoints are drawn from these and your
query is also drawn from B's then it
does seem like you're in somewhat of a
difficult situation now I haven't seen a
sort of a lower bound that's been
formalized at this type but nonetheless
it's something that you know just
something that gives one pause okay so
one really a beautiful line of work
that's been John has been an approximate
nearest neighbor where you say okay well
nearest neighbor sounds difficult what
if we just
want not the nearest neighbor but
anything that's at most see times as far
away as the nearest neighbor what if we
just do that and there there was this
work started by pure indica and rajiv
gidwani and more recently taken up by
Alex and Dhoni and others where they
show these there's this beautiful
framework locality sensitive hashing
that in Euclidean space lets you get
roughly these parameters okay so you get
a data structure for example if you want
to approximate nearest there but you get
a data structure of size and to the 1.25
okay so more than linear but not too bad
and you get a query time of n to the
point 25 which is which is which is good
okay and this is very successful in
practice you know what works well now on
the theory side 11 sort of odd thing
about these bounds is you know so we see
really a good measure of the hardness of
the problem it's really capturing you
know the difficulty of instances it
seems like a sea approximation would
mean very different things for four
different point configurations okay so
for example let's just look at the
standard in this data set that you know
is used in the introductory machine
learning classes this considered an easy
data sex 60,000 images of handwritten
digits how does nearest neighbor work on
this okay so so let's look at for
example C equals 1 which is the actual
nearest neighbor and that has an error
rate of three percent what if we look at
one point to approximate nearest
neighbors and pick one at random ok so
the lots of them pick one at random the
error rate goes up to nine percent and
once you get to to approximate nearest
neighbors the quad at random the error
rate goes up to 51 percent ok so this is
a case in which should say ok well i
really need C to be tiny you know like
1.1 in order for this to fly which means
you get a quadratic data structure size
and the search time is almost linear oh
maybe I shouldn't use locality sensitive
hashing on this thing but actually look
at these sensitive hashing was
fantastically well on this and not just
see approximate nearest neighbors it has
a good chance of finding the exact
nearest neighbor ok so so there's
something you know so so what's happened
I think is that these bound
our it's very impressive that a bound
can be given like this but because they
have thrown away all parameters that
actually govern the difficulty of you
instance they are necessarily somewhat
lives and so could I say yeah comment so
i think the flemish all kinds of things
were and it's not clear why but I mean
there's also like the random kitchen
sinks right like random Gaussian filters
that's a reasonable feature so there's
all kinds of things going on with a mess
which writes right so it might be
specific to this example right but
actually you know it's I think it's a
more general phenomenon the you know we
we do a lot of experiments with these
methods and you know it finds the exact
nearest neighbor more often than you
would imagine for example okay so i'll
talk about to sort of results one having
to do with nearest neighbors search and
want to do with nearest neighbor
classification and both where we are
looking for sort of instance optimality
okay now in terms of nearest neighbors
search the the sort of the two games in
town as far as I can make out it there's
a hashing method and the tree based
methods and they both work extremely
well and so i'll be talking about the
tree method since those have been
analyzed a little bit less okay and the
mother of all three data structures for
nearest neighbor is the KD tree okay so
this is in euclidean space you have your
endpoints you put a box around them and
then you pick a coordinate direction and
you split in the media okay so you're
fifty percent of the points on one side
fifty percent on the other and then you
recurse okay so you have a million
points they're going to half a million a
quarter of a million and you stop when
the leaves have say a thousand points
each okay that that's when you start
building the tree now a query arise so
you take the query go down the tree and
you get to a leaf with a thousand points
in it and you look for the nearest
neighbor amongst those house and you say
that's the nearest neighbor okay so for
example let's say that we realize over
here you would go down into this box and
you would say oh the nearest neighbor is
that point now of course that's not the
nearest neighbor but that's what it says
okay and so it might not it might not
give you the right answer but it's
certainly fast okay which is
which which is a virtue now one thing
that people have done a lot is to look
for ways to sort of reduce the failure
probability of this method okay and
there are two that the two things so
method number one is to use
randomization and so for example to pick
directions uniformly at random from the
unit sphere okay and you know at first
glance it seemed like a bad idea but
I'll just explain in a second how it's
actually used and why this works well
okay and the second is to allow cells
that overlap a little bit okay so in
terms of the data structure this form
that i think is probably would you know
would be considered you know the one to
use these days its forests of randomized
trees so once you randomize the tree you
get something like an lsh data structure
and just like in lsh where you take
multiple copies of it you do the same
thing with the tree so you get a forest
of them and then the error rate just you
know goes down very fast and this is
these are super popular data structures
and so we were interested in analyzing
them okay so so what are the two things
that are going on so the first is that
you pick a direction uniformly at random
from the unit sphere and then you split
it the median we look at a slight
variant of it where instead of spitting
at the median you just pick a random
percentiles you say somewhere between
25th percentile and 75th percentile pick
a number at random let's say sixty split
at the 60th percentile the second thing
is to have overlapping split so the in
other ways to have a buffer zone in the
middle where the points go both ways
okay so the bad case is where you know
your query is here and you split it the
median and it gets separated from its
nearest neighbor so right now I'm only
going to be talking about exact nearest
neighbor search okay so get separated
from its nearest neighbor so to kind of
reduce the charge of that happening what
you say it's okay look the top forty
five percent of points is only going to
go to the left the bottom forty five
percent will go to the right and the
middle ten percent will go both ways
okay and so the data structure becomes
slightly superlinear okay and now when
you get a query you just go one way so
if the queries over here you only go to
the right if it's hope they would go to
the left ok so the query time remains
unchanged but the data straw
sure is a little bigger than before so
for example if you have a five percent
overlap then the struck data structure
size goes up to and to the 1.16 okay so
it becomes higher so these are the
things we want to analyze and so you
have the original KD tree which is not
that great then you have the random
projection tree but the direction is
chosen at random and the splits up
perturb there's a certain beishin and
then you have the thing with the
overlapping splits okay and it turns out
that roughly the same bound holds for
both of these so i'll be talking about
the spill tree but roughly the same
thing goes for the other way as well so
the interesting thing is that you can
give a bound that use that makes no
assumptions about the data okay so pick
any data said you like x1 to xn any
query you like ok and now let's imagine
that we have ordered the points by their
distance from the query so x1 is the
closest point xn is the furthest point
the probability of failure depends
crucially on this quantity okay this is
the and this is you know I'll go through
the argument in a second but you'll see
that this bulk an upper bound and a
lower bond i mean this is this is
approximately tight except where there's
a lot of collinear triples okay so what
is this so it's the distance to the
nearest divided by the distance to the
second nearest plus the distance to the
nearest divided by the distance to the
third nearest and so on so for example
if the nearest neighbor is very close
and everything else is very far away
there's basically zero and if everything
is the same distance this is one those
are the two extremes okay and everything
else lies somewhere in the middle so
this is sort of the potential function
or this is this is really what controls
the research time of this data structure
so sorry so this is for either of them
actually the skill tree or the failure
probability sorry so this is what
controls the failure probability okay so
why is this and the argument is super
simple so I'll just go through it in its
entirety
great yeah failure to find so we want we
want X of one and we want to know what's
the chance did you get something else
back right it doesn't depend on the
overlap solid yes it will but it'll just
that'll just be a term in front so I'll
give the proper bound in a second but
this is basically the difficulty
parameter if one had to pull one out of
the problem okay so so what can go wrong
so the only thing can happen is that so
at each point you're splitting the
points and if the ferry gets separated
from its nearest neighbor initially
there together at the top if at some
point they get separated that's when
you're in trouble and so at each step
you're picking a random direction you're
projecting everything onto that
direction the query goes there the
nearest neighbor goes there the only way
they can be separated because of the
buffer zone is if a lot of points fall
between them okay a huge number of
points basically so to analyze that
let's just look at the case of tweet
points first of all so you have the
query you have the nearest neighbor and
this is some other point okay and it's
this point is a little bit further away
and what we want to know is if you pick
a random direction what's the chance
that this point is going to fall between
these two what's the probability of that
and so the main thing is this is just a
two-dimensional problem okay because you
can make QB the origin and then you just
look at this make this the origin look
at the plane defined by x and y and so
there's the plane in which these things
lie and now the direction you're picking
of course are going to stick out of this
plane but all that matters is the
projection of the direction on that
plane okay and if it's a uniform
Direction overall then it's also a
uniform direction within the plane so
it's just a 2d problem right okay so
this is our query this is the nearest
neighbor into some other point let's say
we pick this direction over here if we
pick a direction like that we are good
because Y is out here and X is over
there so now let's move the direction
clockwise this is the first place at
which we want into trouble the
perpendicular vice the perpendicular to
the line connecting XY because at this
point x and y this is the direction x
and y actually fall onto the same point
so this is the first place at which we
want into trouble now we keep going
these are all bad angles if you project
over here
then why falls between X and Q and this
is the last one would you run into
trouble because Y falls on top of queue
okay so there's this bad angle and the
probability of falling within that angle
is just theta over 2 pi and what is
petah well this is just high school
geometry similar triangles and sines and
cosines like that okay and once you plug
that stuff in you see that the
probability of this happening is the
following it's a half times the distance
to the nearest neighbor divided by the
distance to the other point so if
they're equidistant than the
probabilities I have and if this is
really far away then the probability is
small so it's just that ratio and and
and this is good this is basically tied
unless the points are highly collinear
almost collinear so this is the three
points and of course we actually have n
points so this is the query this is the
nearest neighbor and we want to know
what fraction of these endpoints are
actually going to fall between these so
we're picking a direction at random what
fraction these points are going to fall
between Q and x1 okay and if that
fraction is large like greater than
alpha that's when we are in trouble ok
well the expected fraction is easy to
compute it's just this thing the thing
we were actually calling a potential
function just by linearity of
expectation ok and so that's the
expected for action what's the
probability that the fraction is greater
than alpha that divided by alpha is just
Markov's inequality ok so we get so we
know that the we know what the
probability is that we're going to run
into trouble at the very top level of
the tree ok now things change a little
bit of the second level because at the
top you have a million points and then
the next level you step six hundred
thousand of them okay which 600,000 you
don't really know well the worst case is
the 600,000 that are closest to the
query okay and so and so let's look at a
situation where we have just n points
where we just write the same some but
for the endpoints closest to the query
and then we sum that down the tree okay
and so we're done so it's like it's very
easy and this is the error probability
then ok we just summed over all levels
of the tree
so I equals 0 at the top level than the
second level okay and and we we just
write out the same term at each level
okay so this is the thing we need to
bound this is the thing that controls
really the performance of this data
structure and we need to bound this yeah
very much cola de jure let's say it
could be that either all points are
between all none of them is between
let's say all points except the nearest
ankle all are essentially the same place
so and then I locator spell that is
spread out so it's like the expectation
alone let me tell you the story right so
what we have here is them is an upper
bound what's not clear is that so right
to the expected fraction is this we have
you know in order to bound the chance
that it's greater than alpha we just
divided by alpha and we was taking a
Union bound over the levels of the tree
hi right so it's not that's true so so
the part that's not tied is the alpha
and the sum the pump that is tied is the
expression itself right so this is right
yeah asian is just and then to the
forget example right here so so so for
this method it's it's clear that this is
sort of the difficulty parameter but
exactly like what the dependence on
alpha is for example is or or but or the
number of levels is unclear yeah so
we'll just focus on bounding this thing
and and then plug it into the valve and
the case i'll look at is is sort of a
suitably sort of make sense but but we
do want to like instantiate this bound
for sub one interesting case leaves and
and so i looked at a few you know where
the data have cluster structure where
the data come from a topic model and so
on 11 in one interesting thing to look
at is the case where the data have
bounded doubling
okay so this is a notion of intrinsic
dimension that was introduced but Gupta
crowd gamer and Lee because I think they
wanted a sort of an ngon asymptotic
version of us words dimension and so so
what this says is that you have this
point set and the way we're going to
define its intrinsic dimension is we say
look at bald look at any ball look at
the points to fall in that ball how many
bowls of half the radius you need to
cover those points so for example if
your point set is a line that's embedded
in some super high dimensional space the
doubling dimension is one do see to look
at any bowl and you look at the point
part of the line that's inside the bowl
you need two bolts of half the radius to
cover it so the doubling dimension is
good fun okay and so this also generates
the this also generalizes a
k-dimensional flat because doubling
dimension okay manifolds if you have a
manifold abounded curvature then it has
neighborhoods of with proportional to
the curvature that also had doubling
dimensional k generalizes far sets and
so for doubling dimension you can show
that so I'm not going to go through the
entire argument i'll just give some some
sort of high-level i'll just give some
sort of high-level remarks but basically
what you need to do is to grow the tree
until the sizes of leaves are about K to
the K where K is the dull doubling
dimension and so you get a query time
that's roughly K to the K plus log in ok
now a similar query time this sort of
exponential dependence on k and then the
log n has been obtained for a variety
for lots of other data structures okay
so the real difference over here is that
this is the data structure you know this
quote means quite widely used and you
know had not been analyzed before and so
it's a it's of interest to see what it
does so how do we bound how do we bound
this term given only the doubling
dimension I won't go through the whole
argument but basically the user here's a
very basic question that keeps coming up
again and again in nearest neighbor
analysis okay and the question is this
pick any endpoints in P dimensional
okay and take one of those points let's
call it X how many of the remaining n
minus 1 points can have this as its
nearest neighbor can make all n minus
one of them have this as its nearest
neighbor okay so that's the question
right yeah do you need the RP assumption
or just a building dimension electric
general um yes I'll get to that in a sec
yeah we don't really and so I believe
this was shown by stone in the 70s that
that is basically at most to do that the
other point so maybe it's 5 to the P
other points can have this as its
nearest neighbor okay and the argument
that that he used he was trying to show
the universal consistency of nearest
neighbor which is the topic I will get
to next but for the argument he was
using was he was saying let's look at a
bunch of cones like really narrow cones
subtended at this point X okay and let's
just cover space with these codes okay
these cones are so thin that within each
cone only one point can have X's its
nearest neighbor okay so at this point
can have X's it's near example but
anything else would actually be closer
to this because the cone is so thin i
think the angle has to be like 30
degrees or something like that and so
you get this cover by these very clean
cones and the cones have a fixed angle
so the number of cones you need is just
like to to the dior six to the d or
something like that okay so that's a
that's the argument and then it was
shown more recently by Clarkson that you
can kind of do something like this for
doubling dimension as well okay so if
the doubling dimension is K you can do
something kind of similar with the
doubling dimension and then and then you
can see how this would go naturally into
this because now we have all these terms
that we want to bound and then you can
say let's again do this covering of
space by these cones and how much can
the points in a cone contribute to the
sum and so you do it that way yeah
is this no that is so doubling to
mention is the non asymptotic version
where it holds for all balls yeah so
it's not just as the scale goes to zero
that's right and so that's what makes it
so useful in like the more computer
science-y stuff yeah okay so that's sort
of a high level of the argument so some
open problems on the algorithmic front i
would say it will be nice looking i
think i mean they're all these other
sort of structures that we attribute to
data dictionaries topics you know what
you know what does this look like for
those kinds of data and second is this a
good predictor of when nearest neighbor
of which nearest neighbor problems are
easier than others so when i look at
these mirrors experiments comparing the
earth labour methods the interesting
thing is never is this method two
percent better than that method it's
that look at these different data sets
on this data set nearest neighbor works
so well and on this other data set it
just works so much worse you know what
is going on what's the difference right
it's it's much more like on the data
side and then the actual algorithm side
and so you'll be interesting if you know
if this if this for example it sort of
correlated with with those sort of
observe behaviors yeah so maybe I'm like
this kind of like measure the complexity
with open different algorithms are not
only two percent I just had a lot much
but can you using this measure can you
distinguish between like good and bad
algorithms just using this magic item s
communities like the right gouge vote
for the difficulty of the problem yeah
so could be interesting right right so
it might be so for example maybe it's
possible to go back and and analyze you
know the failure probability of lsh at
finding the exact nearest neighbor okay
since it really does seem to you know do
a decent job at finding the exact
nearest neighbor very often right maybe
one could just go back and analyze it
and maybe something like this pops up
again I don't know that will be
interesting yeah when you said yours
NeighborWorks all did you mean as a
classifier or did you mean as that these
algorithms work well it on the server
correlation between those two things
that you know when it men whereas good
statistically it's also relatively I
honestly haven't the faintest idea
honestly fix ability to believe that's
only the search for any estate yeah so
so so my guess is that the two things
are are actually unrelated but you know
so so over here I'm just talking about
its performance and actually finding the
exact nearest neighbor and you know but
but but yeah that'll be interesting if
there was some connection right so now
I'm going to get to the other side which
is the nearest neighbor classification
and so here we'll move to a slightly
more general setting on in the
statistical theory of nearest neighbor
the whole game has to do with five
minutes okay up quick has to do with
generality no assumptions as general as
possible that's what it's all about okay
I'm in sort of this a nonparametric
estimation okay so the data lies in some
metric space okay and and so we can look
at one nearest neighbor we can look at
Kenya and snail the K closest in you
average and actually we typically let K
go grow within like law again or
something okay so now we assume that
there's some underlying distribution you
from which the points come and at any
value of x the label is stochastic the
chance that it's one is some ADA of X
okay and so the very best classifier is
one that at point x you predict one if
that area is greater than a half
otherwise you predict zero that's the
best thing you can do and that's called
the Bayes optimal classifier and
achieves the best possible error which
is our star some some horror okay
whatever our star happens to be and in
general this Bayes optimal boundary is
something crazy okay it's something like
really strange-looking thing okay
nothing that we can hope to nail down
with a finite data said okay and so
we're going to be looking at the
k-nearest neighbor classify based on n
labeled points which is some sort of
hopefully discreet approximation to that
boundary and what we're hoping is that
as n grows this converges to that okay
does them okay so what are some
questions are interesting so one thing
we'd like to do is to just bound the
error of this okay how much worse is
this and that and and you know following
the methodology that I was espousing we
just like to give assumption free browns
okay so it might not look pretty but
it'll help you understand what controls
the what controls the difficulty of the
problem okay and in this case actually
it's pretty simple now hitting bounds
that look a little bit nicer a little
more bit more interpreter with
smoothness matters and that's because
you know having a distribution of Y that
looks like that so this is X that's why
the probability that Y is equal to 1 ada
it's much easier than this because you
know here here you need to predict 10 10
10 it's very jagged so this looks like a
harder situation than that and so the
smoothness of this ADA function really
matters and what I'll what I'll show is
that nearest neighbor really demands its
own notion and smoothness rather than
simply taking the stuff that you know is
used for regression and if you use that
you get upper and lower bounds that are
qualitatively similar for every
distribution in this movement class okay
it's not this sort of minimax thing
where the upper bug holds for everything
at the lower bound only holds for one
item in the class okay so so they
actually match for every distribution in
the class and then finally I'll talk
about consistency so what we'd like is
universe
consistency and universal consistency
means consistency without assumptions
okay you're not assuming for example
that ADA is continuous or anything like
that you just you know no matter what
the distribution is it's got to be
consistent and that was shown in the 70s
for Euclidean space by stone look just a
wonderful result but those arguments
actually don't generally don't
generalize to two other metric spaces
and it turns out they just like starting
from this point and using a different
kind of argument which is basically just
calculus we get universal consistency in
a much richer class in metric spaces
okay so let's see so so let me just so
let me start let me just talk a little
bit about smoothness since I I don't
have much time so how do we parametrize
smoothness the usual way to do this is
this sort of holder condition alpha
equals 1 means lip [ __ ] and then there's
another thing that matters so this just
says that ADA doesn't change too fast
okay the other thing that matters is
that so the boundary is really the
points at which this ADA function is a
half that's the points at which it's a
toss-up whether the label is 0 or 1 it
could be either way and the points that
are like point 5 1 and point 49 those
are also bad okay so let's look at this
region around a half a with T margin
around a half places where the ADA is
between a half plus or minus T and we
want to we are hoping that this region
has very low probability mass and
there's the ciba commandment condition
where it says okay the probability mass
of these regions is at most some
function okay and and so the classical
bounds have been given in terms of these
these people show that okay under these
under these two parameterizations of
smoothness this is the kind of bound
that is the best possible and it turns
out that nearest neighbor achieves these
lands
so the smoothness condition that I
advocate which is a little different is
the following so the nearest neighbor it
does not matter how ADA changes you know
so we want to know how much does a to
change within this interval we don't
want to measure the rate of ADA's change
with respect to the length between X and
X prime but rather the amount of
probability mass between X and X Prime
and that makes a huge difference okay so
instead of measuring how much this
function ADA changes in terms of
distance measure how much it changes by
probability mass because this is really
the only thing that matters in nearest
neighbor okay and so we get this other
notion we also use the same smoothness
parameter but now instead of distance we
just plugged in probability mass okay
and it turns out that if you do this
which is a simple enough thing the
bounds just becomes way cleaner and you
get upper and lower bounds that are
really close on on the distribution okay
and and it's a generalization of the
previous notion if it's out holder
continues then it's also smooth in this
sense and so what do these bounds look
like it said that the failure
probability for nearest neighbor for any
distribution in the class is really just
the amount of probability mass that lies
within the one over square root K margin
of the distribution okay and so one half
plus or minus 1 over square root K and
that's really what matters the amount of
probability mass that love this is
margin around one this is Marge so the
decision boundary is all points for
which ADA is exactly a half and these
are all points for which it's a half
plus or minus 1 over square root K what
is the probability mass of that region
and that turns out to be a good upper
bound and lower bound okay so so
unfortunately I don't think I'm going to
get to the universal consistency but but
I understand but I'm open problems so so
we were able to show universal
consistency in a range of metric spaces
but not all of them
and so here's a very interesting
question is there any metric space in
which nearest neighbor fails to be
consistent like is it is it ever not
consistent and that's not known is there
some sort of crazy metric space in which
in which this method when you say what
that would mean again so just in words
like a metric space images fails we can
see what is that so what what we need so
consistency means that if you let K grow
as a function of n then the k-nearest
neighbor classifier converges to the
Bayes optimal classifier ok so or rather
the error rate of decay nearest neighbor
classifier converges to the Bayes error
rate ok so that holds for any
distribution in Euclidean space and
we've shown that it holds 40 you know a
bunch of metric spaces basically metric
for example doubling dimension bounded
or spaces that are directionally limited
but but if she leaves open the
possibility that there are some metric
spaces in which k nearest neighbor is
not consistent metric measure spaces so
it will also depend on mu and so that's
kind of an interesting question and and
another question is so this sort of
assumption free consistency or bounds in
more general distance spaces so the the
stuff that I just like sort of went over
very briefly realize a lot upon tools
that would develop or analysis in metric
spaces and so if it can be generalized
to some sort of slightly even slightly
more general topological spaces then we
could look at things like KL divergence
and in other distance functions of
interests that are not metrics thank
yeah oh so it was a somewhat of a
disconnect the water views in the first
in the second half of the well I'm just
very different questions once the
algorithmic ones the statistical so in
the following sense right so for the
first half the bad case is when there
are lots of points which are nearby
right probably the same where is in the
second view right where you think of the
points being from a distribution that's
actually a good case because any of
those points is probably equally good
for sufficiently right so then yeah
right so in fact it's the wrong to
measure in the first half right I think
the second half is roughly the correct
view right and sort of measuring the
first half is not correct you're killing
me that was my question yeah so that
would be that would be cool that they
complimented you know if it turned out
to be complementary slightly different
way the algorithmic question is not
what's the nearest neighbor is what's
the label of the nearest name yeah and
so you know the then the algorithmic
complexity depends on the label function
as well as the metric space itself and
I'm suggesting that in the second view
you know any setting where there are
lots of nearby neighbors which are very
close you actually have a lot of
confidence on what the correct level is
that's my suggestion whereas when they
aren't too many clothes by points you
are an outlier land and probably even if
you find the nearest neighbor it's not
fearless yeah that's a very interesting
for the question would be nice to a big
rubber like what's the right way to
formalize this thing yeah yeah I mean I
was about to ask the question in the
first half and I said wait I know San
Jose others paper other papers would you
yeah well I never made the good a trip
so thank you for bringing that up yeah
the paper is really an emotion that also
takes into account the marginal weight
of poets which we the deliciousness will
be violent somehow takes like a similar
situation right right yeah so be
interesting to sort of see if this with
one can come up with some sort of bounds
both weights right what do you I'm
selling them doing that you're gonna
talk about this K&N I thought you're
gonna have an like it not lately but
precise formula perhaps I thought it's
gonna be lucky Commissioner what is the
question at the end cuz I've talked
about the cake look doing 50 which is
interesting automatically perspective
but it's fully not useful I don't go I
because you're not get it take yeah so I
so did you ever get any insight of what
is that I k I mean from this kind of
like formulas all the short answer is no
the honest answer is no but sort of the
sort home but the other answer is that
you know if it falls in this alpha
smoothness class then this is what you
would set K to right it's just that we
have no idea what alpha smoothness
closet falls into if any okay so that
the answer is no basically I don't have
any good inside [ __ ]